hello everyone I'll be talking
about a bashir flow today who of you
know what a posse airflow is pretty much
everyone I'm quite surprised who of you
uses up a sheer flow that's fantastic is
like for me it's a fantastic place to be
to talk about Apache airflow and I'll
tell you why
very quickly you know all about so a
Bashir flow is an Orchestrator that
orchestrates different workflows dynamic
workflows it's dynamic
it's Python is extensible it's scalable
so like all the good things but you know
everything because you know and use air
flow so I won't talk a lot about this
what I'll be talking about I'll tell you
about how we work with our flow the poly
d a team I'm from Paula dear and from
Paula via company so we have a whole
team working on air flow what the air
flow is about I'll tell you what
advantages or of air flow are comparing
to other similar solutions where we are
now in the past year flow when 1.10 and
what's coming in uppish air flow 2.0
everyone is waiting for that so i'll
just go fast so i'm your aquatic i'm a
principal software engineer at pool area
most upper shear flow committee and napa
shear flow pmc member so I'm just very
closely in the team which develops air
flow itself which is an open source
project project I'm also certified GCP
architect and a lot of access ex-googler
X CTO in my own company x choir member i
chose to come back to the engineering
career after being CTO in my own company
that's actually a choice that i advise
you to make at some point of time it's
very good team so we have quite a big
team working on on apogee air flow for
now it's six people all together we had
in the past we had three more members we
are changing quite frequently and we
also have another team and I put all the
names there because those people are
actually the community and people
working on the product are important so
we also have another team which works on
a per share flow this time about
developing new up a share flow website
which every was also developed in Paulo
dia
and I will show results of the work of
the team as well at the end so a few
words about my company not too not too
long because we don't have a lot of time
we have 70 people here in Warsaw we are
very strongly engineering driven but we
also have UX and design department we
traditionally developed mobile
application software so mobile
applications and back-end for those
applications but for more than two years
we grew from zero to like 15 maybe 18
people the part that is working on open
source software and cloud and actually
it's it's a new model that is very
surprisingly that's very surprising it
works very well we get paid for
contributing to open source by our
customers so this is fantastic place to
be Sao Paulo end up a sheer flow we
started in August 2018 so more than a
year ago with two people like myself and
colleague of mine and now December we
are at December 2019 we have six people
and nine people worked on the team over
the time during the time this is
something that our customer wanted us to
do we develop 130 operators operator is
the the part that connects our flow to
external service we developed those
operators for 18 Google cloud platform
services this was our main focus and our
customer wanted us to do that we
developed a converter from easy to
airflow do you know you see who knows
you see quite a lot of people so you see
is a legacy I would say Hadoop workflow
management tool and we developed a tool
to automatically convert
who's it workflow I will not talk about
this but a lot of people find it very
interesting we can talk later about this
after at the after party or tomorrow the
idea behind hoozy to airflow was is that
the world is better placed one external
at a time yeah i one external less at a
time so who's it where flow is
reflecting that and we developed also
new Apache airflow website which I will
show later however that's not all
because the our customer is so generous
and so happy for us to
work in the open-source software that
they generally told us you have a
freedom to do whatever you want to make
the aya Papa shear flow better and
contribute to it so we took our time to
make our make ourselves much more
productive in developing whatever
customer wanted and in the time we had
we also developed a lot of things which
are which were just for the community
for the for everyone who uses our flow
so we've done a lot of documentation
improvements we restructure the whole
documentation for our flow I developed
and together with my friends breeze you
know it's a breeze to develop our flow
you see that the pan yeah so I it's
improved development environment and I
have a completely whole 45-minute talk
just about this and I did it six times
already so it's my beloved child we
helped to migrate to Python 3 so new our
flow 2-0 is Python 3 only everyone claps
yeah everyone yeah we have three weeks
to go so - Python 2 - end of life we've
implemented pileinn we are continuing
implementing pilant compatibility we
have a lot of thailand compliancy and
testing the quality of our code we've
introduced pre-commit framework and I
also have a talk about this run for like
20 30 minutes I can talk about that
because that's fantastic thing and you
should if you don't use pre-commit
framework which is called pre commit
calm then you should now then we have
rearranged lamented the whole
environment for CI for continuous
integration and we are continuing
working on that and making it better and
we also that's that's also one of the
things so we had a lot of time to
develop this because we developed since
we have to develop all those 130
operators we didn't want to develop them
by hand or we did initially but we all
realized how repetitive task it is so we
developed a tool to generate those
operators automatically and that's why
we had a lot of time to implement a lot
of other stuff so we just improved our
productivity 10 times by just and
generating the code there it's an open
source product you can actually use it
to generate your own operators if you
I can talk about that later as well no
time today to talk about everything
we've done and last but not least we
just last week switched test from nose
tests to PI tests and that's fantastic
thing use by test not know stressed or
not standard unit test whatever my test
is so great as a result we not only
developed what we developed but we also
have to up our shear flow meters I'm one
and Camille is another one more
commuters to come from our team I'm sure
it will happen shortly and I also always
invite us to become a PMC member PMC
project management committee for those
who do not know a Parsi this is kind of
overlooking board of the project and our
role is to make sure that the product is
done you're using Apache or following
Apache way so vendor-neutral and stuff
like that so making sure that we are
doing the good thing according to Apache
way final word about our company we are
super open source and community friendly
we also have an Apache beam team working
so we have more than 15 people working
on open source software exclusively and
getting paid for that which is fantastic
so we run Apache beam Meetup
we already had first edition and more to
come we ran worse air flow meet up as
well
we had one Meetup and tomorrow and I
will tell about that at the end of the
talk we also have a workshop for first
time a partial flow contributors run in
our company this is an event which is
accompanying PI data or so and we also
in the past had our own conference mc5
year's big the same size or bigger than
this one five years from 200 300 people
to 600 people I was the main organizer
there that was an experience which I
won't forget and I have at this time I
have to thank Rafal and all the other
organizers of of Pi data also because
they are doing fantastic job it's like
great place to be here it's like super
cool and cool that they agreed for us
with
to to connect this workshop because they
announced the workshop we announced the
PI data also on our meetup group and I
think this collaboration is great
now going back to the main topic mmm so
why choose Apache airflow over any of
the others ordered other workflow
management tools that you can have as we
have all this Lois you z-cube flow next
flow agro traffic whatever lots of them
but our flow is standing out and I will
tell you why so first of all air flow is
not a processing engine air flow is an
Orchestrator our fruit do not do and it
doesn't do anything like almost anything
it just tells others what to do this is
like this is how you should think about
air flow so just tell order what to do
and does it and to do it in synchronous
way so it's exactly as a conductor in
your in an orchestra or in choir
I'm actually an ex choir east as you may
be so as I sang 30 years in the choir so
I know exactly that when we perform the
conductor is not needed unless something
wrong happens and that's exactly what
our flow is so the air flow is
monitoring what's going on and whenever
there is anything it might intervene it
might restart a failing job or might
give to information to the operator that
it needs to be restarted and mostly is
it's almost idle or very idle but it
doesn't touch the data like in ideal
world all the operators are not touching
the data they are just telling others
what to do what is super cool and that's
why we are a PI data conference so the
PI part of it
air flow is all Python not only written
in Python but you also develop your work
workflows in Python so the same people
who can write the operators the same
people who can do the data science stuff
and know Python they can also develop
the way the work flows and this is
actually a super big strength and every
time we hear from others I would like to
write an XML or yam description of the
workflow we say no this is exactly not
what air flow is doing air flow is using
Python as the source of truth and helps
this makes data scientists or anyone who
is in who knows a little bit of Pi and
Python the power to do the work flows on
them on their own
because it's super boring to write XML
and it's quite cool to write byte that's
that's actually what I feel - and what
else law does as well it allows you to
write this kind of workflows yeah I mean
imagine writing this kind of workflow in
XML or young or whatever I mean no
forget however in air flow you can
develop this kind of workflows in like
hundred lines of code pretty much or
maybe two hundred but is it's a code
it's a code that you can test you can
attest automatically you can you know
debug the code while the the workflow is
generated that's why that's that's the
power of our flow like if you have
really complex workflows hair flow is
your friend our flow has a new UI maybe
the UI is not like the best nicest or
kind of modern I wouldn't say it's
modern but it works I mean we know that
I will tell you from where we know that
but but the the UI is quite great
because you can monitor and check what's
going on with your workflows in
production in even if you have hundreds
or thousands of them you have a UI and
you can see and rerun the tasks check
the logs etc etc see the status from the
UI and so that's cool
what's even cooler air flow has also CLI
so you can do a lot of stuff why does
interfacing with it via CLI making
commands making finding tasks listing
tasks etc so this is also good for for
developers who do not like to look at
the web UI
so where are flow shines airflow signs
with the regular batch jobs so it's not
a streaming solution that's the
important thing like lots of people are
trying to use air flow for streaming our
flow is not good at streaming it's good
and regular much ETL jobs which are
processed in fixed intervals of data
managing complex dependencies as you saw
there it allows for bacteria this is
actually one of the most important
features of air flow if you want to read
process part of your data because
something changed either the data or you
fix the code that processes the data you
can rerun any portion of the data for
from the past from the point that you
need to rerun and airflow will just do
it without you know yourself knowing
exactly what our dependence is it will
figure out what to do and you can rerun
historical data processing and that's
that's super cool and you can interface
to literally hundreds of different
systems so we have there are hundreds of
operators in our flow and surprisingly
what we found out during such meetups
and conferences that people are using
our flow in a in some strange ways so a
lot of a number of people are actually
using air flow too like they use their
own system to generate DAGs
generate Python code which they run
through air flow it's kind of strange
because you're supposed to write the
Python code yourself but there are some
very good uses where the Python code
might be generated and it turns out that
it's much easier to generate such a
Python code than XML files in - even in
many circumstances I can I see some
faces which are surprised yes I was
surprised too
but it works and it makes sense I can
tell you that actually who's it your
flow is doing exactly this it's taking
XML files and generates Python code and
this Python is fully readable like like
if human I wrote it and it was super
easy action so coming back a little
state of the tin will you know pinwheel
is the thing here in case you didn't
know this spinning stuff so we have
several one-on-one ten versions or from
one to ten to the one to ten six and we
have one dot 10.7 in the making actually
at the conference today I just pushed a
last change to make the Travis green for
one to 10.7 so it's keeps finger cross
crossed
next few days it might be released it
was it is actually actually deployed in
thousands of companies and lots of big
companies are using air flow and our
flow is actually using I mean I think
it's one of the most popular especially
in Python world the most popular
solution for for this kind of workflows
it's on the rise of usage I mean we see
that we hear that we have some
statistics that show us like many many
more people are using air flow everyday
and we have two zero version which we
work on in master it's not stable
it fails from time to time it is not
backwards compatible not fully backwards
compatible there are some
incompatibility switch with document
very thoroughly what kind of changes you
have to do to migrate but we are deeply
into 2-0 development and that's that's
what I'm talking about mainly has a
result you see this Apogee feather and
the big fan of Apache Software
Foundation I've been to the conference
Apache con conference month ago and I've
learned how fantastic organization it is
up a sheer flow is an Apache project and
it has an Apache stamp of approval
because it's a top-level project which
means that it is run according to the
Apache way and this is something that
makes it much better this is one reason
why you want to use products like Apache
airflow over some other even open-source
project because you know that it's
following certain rules and I'll talk
about how we can like we know that it's
popular a lot of people are using it we
know that that there are some changes
coming and we have to be prepared from
from that so we figure out right now we
think and talk in the PMC and between
committers how to stay relevant because
it's easy to fall into the trap okay we
are the most user used workflow system
in the world people will use it use us
anyway no we have to think what's coming
and we have to be prepared for that so
cloud native is coming I think I don't
have to explain kubernetes and all the
ways of running your deployments is it's
something that is super important ap is
our backbone of motor software so you
really want to be give your customers
the capability of interfacing with your
product using some well-defined
easy-to-use api's for now we have UI we
have the CLI we have some experimental
API but it's not very good
doesn't let you do everything he would
like to user interface mad matters yeah
so we would like to to have a little bit
fresher user interface it doesn't look
appealing if you use it and I'm big fan
of using nice interfaces for example the
main reason why I'm afraid you CP over
AWS not the main but one of the reasons
is that the UI there is modern like
actually it's nice it's nice to use it
in console so we want to do the same
performance and reliability are super
important for many people of course
because you want to use your computing
power efficiently there are many
services that are coming many services
that you we don't know even right now or
many services are changing very fast and
we want to be able to interface with all
those services and one last but not
least this is an Apache project yeah so
Apache airflow is all about community
apache moto which we learned at the
apache con is like community over code
so the important thing is like you build
great community of people and as a
result great code comes after it's not
the other way around and actually a
Bashir flow is has a great community
fantastic people super fun to work with
them super challenging at a time what
you have to have to also take care about
the community and not only about
community of developers or of
contributors to the code but also about
the community of users for many reasons
one reason is like they are our users we
love our users we want them to be happy
but secondly our users we want our users
to become contributors as well so we've
learned that a lot of people are
developing stuff extending operators
developing their own things and we want
them to contribute back and this is like
this is really what we would love to do
and that's what we are doing so we are
super lucky today
because this is the first time anybody
outside of the very close group of
people sees the result of survey survey
that we just finished so we ran for my
friend my colleague from my company
Thomas robotics started it two weeks ago
more than two weeks ago it ran for the
last two weeks
it's fresh of the press we haven't yet
published the results you will see some
of that we found some surprises and
we've learned that we are generally
going in the right direction we have to
change and adapt a little bit what we
planned for 2-0 but generally we were
thinking right and that's good so a few
general numbers how often do you use our
flow so most of the people are using our
flow daily or weekly it's super if you
use air flow you use it all the time and
that becomes your daily tool to use what
do you use air flow for a lot has been
said about different machine learning
frameworks today data flow is more
targeted for the traditional ETL
processing but it's still useful in many
cases for machine learning pipelines so
30% of people are using it for machine
learning almost everyone uses it for
data processing some people are using
for automaking DevOps so it's kind of CI
equivalent yes you can use air flow for
that is not intended but what can be
improved performance schedule
performance web UI here people would
like to have it nice or logging alerting
surprisingly well it's not what wasn't a
surprise but we've learned how many
people want to have better documentation
better onboarding better technical
documentation better examples how - yeah
that's what you would expect from a good
product better reliability impor
important the REST API
yeah 30% people want to have an
authentication authorization these are
the top things that people would like to
get improved and these are the things
that people would like to be implemented
new production ready docker image
declarative way of writing DAGs well
that's something that we don't really
feel is good because that's not what air
flow is but still 50% people would like
to so we provide converters like lose it
to air flow and we also have a talk with
common workflow language framework which
produces kind of declarative standard
for declaring workflows and they've
written their own converted to our flow
so maybe we don't have to do it in air
flow but maybe we can just expose
information how you can write the
clarity tags and convert them into
Python horizontal Alto scaling
important examples how to sandboarding
documentation again appearing here a
synchronous operator stateless web
server our web server is stateful it can
take five minutes to load in some
installations that's not good to start
so we want to have it more stateless
okay native executor that's an important
thing I will talk about this a little
bit and I don't know whom but some
people said that they have everything
they need that's fairly surprised I've
never felt that using any software that
I have everything that I need but
apparently some people do so how do we
address that in air flow to 0 this is
the finally that the clue of that of the
talk so cloud native is coming so more
details about from our from our survey
so we have different kinds of executors
in our flow so we can execute it either
locally on your local machine or in the
cluster kubernetes cluster or in celery
cluster still a lot of people are using
celery cluster they some of them use
kubernetes and some people use all of
them a lot of people are still using
airflow as a local executor which means
that everything all the orchestration
happens on one machine because if you
have a small load that's perfectly
enough and that's ok this is also local
executor is also a production ready
executor however more interesting thing
is like we asked specifically about
about kubernetes because this is the
cloud native we were talking about so
30% of people the highest voted answer
was that they do not plan to use
kubernetes new term that was a big
surprise for us because we kind of
living in a bubble that everyone is
moving with kubernetes apparently not so
maybe this doesn't look good for
kubernetes but you can see that there
are some answers which are which we
broke down about like whether they use
or they will use or they can use
kubernetes so if you summarize it a
little bit differently you will see that
either use or can use kubernetes in for
foreseeable future
it's like 70% people and/or will use it
or can use kubernetes which means that
command test is important but it also
means that we shouldn't abandon the
salary approach which is
nann kubernetes native so what we do we
thought and we've implemented almost
like we've implemented the
proof-of-concept 4k native executor
which is you know hay native kind of
cloud run lambda functions AWS and we
found out that it doesn't work right we
it has too many limitations for so
basically work work workers of Apache
airflow are not as stateless as quenette
native would like it to be so we
abandoned that idea and we actually had
a special interest group between the
committee's okay which was called
special interest group k native and we
just renamed it to special interest
group scalability because we abandoned a
native in this instead we are working on
something called native airflow
executors so again connect my friend
colleague from from Paulo dia he made a
proof of concept and we will do a native
executor which uses pub/sub type of
communication thing Kafka think tops up
in there are other other implementation
readies its horizontally auto scalable
yeah and that's it and we are working
this so we will go more cloud native you
will be able to deploy it at different
providers so AWS Google cloud whatever
you can use it either as a service if
somebody opens it up like currently
astronomer and a composer from Google
there are two biggest services of which
are serving up our shear flow as a
service so we still want to help those
guys to be able to provide it as a
service we use generic pops-up
architecture for communication which is
more kind of cloud way of doing things
out native there is no database
communication between between components
so something that we were removing from
the current set up and we are using we
are working on production optimized or
creed image this is my kind of beloved
tried I worked on it for four months now
I mean just like five minutes here if I
think there are among other things but
it's coming it's soon monitoring we
decided we don't want to do our own kind
of monitoring solution we rather
integrate with standard monitoring tools
like stats D we just export more metrics
we work
how to integrate primitivism kubernetes
we use metrics in order to do horizontal
scalability so for example we will
monitor how many tasks we have an in a
queue if more than X then we will escape
our horizontal autoscaler will scale out
scale up I never know and and this is
basically the approach for cloud native
with a api's so we know that we need
modern api and we work on one it will be
HTTP based API so CLI and webserver they
will both use the same HTTP based API
between scheduler on workers as I
mentioned we will use pub sub
communication rather than API like it is
also an API but it's kind of different
not HTTP based it will be generic so it
will need not be tied to particular
deployment you have so you'll be able to
deploy it on both kubernetes cluster and
set every cluster and whatever
mezzos if you still are using that or
whatever better authentication
authorization which will open
capabilities of having multi-tenant
apache airflow because right now a per
share flow has single database and it's
not protected in any way you cannot
separate the data between different
users if we want to make it happen
because service providers want it so UI
so 97% people almost everyone actually
used the UI this is a good thing some
people use CLI some people even use the
experimental API and small number of
people created their own API but we see
that actually the UI is useful and we
have more details we actually broke down
which views are most useful etc etc so
we have all the data and we know what is
important so one of the things we want
to implement make UI refresh right now
you have to refresh it to get fresh data
its 2020 it should refresh itself
finally modern design possibly maybe
material design use api's for
communication
with and not DB because right now you I
actually calls DB and get the data from
DB by via SQL calls SQL alchemy it's not
good
better authentication authorization
stateless webserver it's already done
pretty much like we have almost
stateless webserver better
responsiveness okay performance and
reliability we have working progress to
automate performance testing so that you
will be able to test before release if
you have any performance gains or losses
losses we have monitoring of performance
characteristic we have improving
webserver scheduler performance project
which is running on their own we have
internal instrumentation of
optimizations so that the the users will
be able to monitor their own DAGs and
see where the bottlenecks are so this is
this is something that we are planning
for many services we currently the
operators are bound to the release of
air flow so with 110 to came a set of
operators we want to change it we know
that migration to 2.0 will take time so
we are introducing a new approach moving
operators to completely new import path
changing import path into 0 and
backporting 210 so we will be able to
use operators from air flow to 0 which
have many new features and there are
many more operators you will be able to
use it in any previous 1.10 version or
few previous 1.10 version yeah that's
repeated and for in the future we will
work on different packaging cover flow
so that you'll be able to install those
separately
now community over code documentation no
guide on best practices no documentation
is not clear enough this was highly
voted answers so we got google season of
docs program which we run together with
Google which improved onboarding best
practices architecture deployment
options we have better structure both
user and the developer documentation was
improved and we worked together with
technical writers from India and Russia
to get the decision of Doc's working we
developed the new website very nice
modern this is done work sponsored by
Google Cloud and done by palladium
and we have some community over code
development environment so we have a
development environments which can get
you up and running as a developer in ten
minutes
with great integration with ID well the
command well documented and allows you
to run and debug that the Dougs locally
and finally we have a fully debuggable
debugger will do a back executor
cooperations with all other company data
band AI and that's end of my talk i have
to speed up i would like to invite you
to the workshop that is tomorrow at 7 at
5:30 in our company at paula dia in a
moment i will open up 10 more places
because we already have a full house but
especially for phi theta also we will
open up new places if you want to learn
how to contribute to open source
software like apple shear flow we can
teach you and you can subscribe there
for now you can be subscribed to the
waitlist but i will open in a moment
10 more places so that everyone who
subscribes so I can join thank you very
much thank you very much
[Applause]